j abou khalil merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer votre réaction à cette
démission du gouvernement elle était
inévitable selon vous oui bonsoir
alors tout d'abord et d'une victoire du
peuple libanais qui s'est exprimée
depuis samedi avec des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui se sont
rassemblées place des martyrs à beyrouth
une mobilisation continue depuis et
alors évité il était inévitable que ce
gouvernement démissionne
encore une fois c'est libéralement n'est
pas le seul à porter cette
responsabilité derrière lui la
responsabilité celle du classe politique
il dirige le pays depuis 30 ans et qui
est responsable de la négligence de la
corruption et de la catastrophe
dagon témoigne à beyrouth le 4 août de
l'année dernière alors avec votre parti
vous appelez de vos voeux un nouveau
front de l'opposition qui passerait par
une alliance de partis citoyens c'est ce
que demandait d'ailleurs un des
manifestant es ce que le moment est venu
aujourd'hui vous
oui absolument et tout est mis en oeuvre
pour parvenir à former ce front malgré
de nombreuses autres tacle naturellement
et partis d'opposition aujourd'hui
ressenti le poids de la responsabilité
qui est la leur essaye de répondre de la
meilleure manière qui soit à la demande
et vous vous y prendre
l'univers comment comptez vous vous y
prendre très concrètement alors il est
il est certain que hors village est très
claire dans le champ politique d'années
entre les parcours politique
confessionnel qui sont au pouvoir depuis
la fin de guerre civile en 1990 et de
l'autre côté
l'ensemble des forces politiques des
fortes y sont nés de la révolution
d'octobre du 16 octobre 2009 elle
également des parties plus anciens qui
s'étaient inscrits dont une au petit
réformiste depuis très longtemps et
qu'ils étaient écartés du pouvoir à ce
titre aujourd'hui des négociations
intenses sont en cours pour annoncer un
second des positions
qui ne saurait tarder et qui mènerait
cette bataille pour imposer est demandé
avec la pression populaire qui
continuera dans l'est dans la rue la
mise en place d'un nouveau allemand
indépendant qui soit capable de mélissa
de transition et d'organiser organiser
des élections pour permettre à
emplacements de cette élite politique ou
quoi la sni table du souk cible avant
avant ce crime de la crise économique
dont souffre le lan est depuis bien
longtemps et est ce que vous pensez
qu'une alliance entre tous ces partis
d'opposition soient réellement possible
absolument et alors il est certain qu'il
ya des obstacles qui sont surmontables
les mémoires dernier le parcours que
nous allons très ensemble entre forte de
l'opposition depuis le 17 octobre ont
permis de construire une relation de
confiance il ya eu un travail comment
énorme qui a été qui a été fait et qui
continue lui qui se concrétisera dans
les jours à venir pour vous désormais
quel scénario possible qui est en
meilleure position qu'elle si vous
aimeriez voir comme premier ministre
alors la question n'est pas pied on
aimerait voir mais selon quels critères
nous aimerions voir les marchés et quand
je voulais dire nous voulons des figures
indépendant de la classe politique des
partis politiques ont créé sionnel des
personnalités compétentes et aussi les
personnalités qui soit capable de mener
cette bataille entre la classe politique
la question des noms et secondaires à
monsieur le principal que ces
personnalités
elles sont nombreuses au niveau remplit
ces critères bas merci beaucoup
naji abu khalil d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre du comité exécutif du parti
libanais bloc national